all right let's start today with news
out of Russia and Ukraine these
headlines are sort of unbelievable I
I've been a stop short of calling them
kafka-esque but it's almost appropriate
the Associated Press reports that
Vladimir Putin the Russian president has
declared martial law
in the annexed regions of Ukraine now
that headline might make sense if that
there was really an annexation that took
place what we're really talking about is
occupied regions of Ukraine
in which Putin is claiming sovereignty
but in which there really is no
sovereignty and so it's kind of a weird
thing to say I'm declaring martial law
in parts of a different country which is
fundamentally what Putin is doing but of
course his perspective would be a
different one let's look at a little bit
of this article and we'll talk about the
reasons for this and the implications
and sort of what comes next
um Associated Press once again Russian
President Vladimir Putin declared
martial law Wednesday in the four
regions of Ukraine that Moscow annexed
and gave additional emergency powers to
the heads of all regions of Russia Putin
didn't immediately spell out the steps
that would be taken under martial law I
think we can guess some of them but said
his order was effective starting
Thursday his decree gives law
enforcement agencies three days to
submit specific proposals and orders the
creation of territorial Defense Forces
in those four annexed regions the um
this statement here from Putin again
it's it's all extremely dystopian quote
we are working to solve very difficult
large-scale tasks to ensure Russia's
security and safe future to protect our
people
huh those who were on the front lines
are undergoing training at firing ranges
and training centers should feel our
support and know that they have our big
great country and unified people behind
their back sounds a little bit trumpy
quite frankly
um the Associated Press article also
adds the Upper House of Russia's
Parliament was set to quickly seal
Putin's decision to impose martial law
again the regions we're talking about
are Danette Carson luhansk and
zapparizia draft legislation indicates
it may involve restrictions on travel
and public Gatherings tighter censorship
and broader Authority for law
enforcement agencies think about the
Evil Genius of this right
uh it's not even your country you say oh
yeah we're annexing these parts of the
country
it's not formally done and I got it I I
understand that when a country is
annexing part of another the idea of
formality often what you're talking
about is just years of it sort of being
under the control and then you say well
I guess now it's kind of annex that
definitely has not happened and then you
say now that this is part of our country
and we've annexed this we're going to
impose further restrictions and further
repress and suppress reporting from the
area Etc the belief there's a few
different beliefs sort of like most
likely lowest hanging fruit priorities
here
one would be
legal cover for the wave of repressions
that are certainly that is certainly to
come as absurd as that cover is hey this
is Russia now and so now we're imposing
martial law the other aspect of this and
a couple people wrote to me said you
know David it's kind of silly to say
you're like imposing martial law in any
kind of formal way because
it's a war zone and so by definition
it's all kind of under the control at
least ostensibly of the military so to
now declare the martial law it's it kind
of is under a de facto martial law type
situation because it's militaries
fighting each other
um we're looking at a forced
mobilization of ukrainians in the area
to start getting the ukrainians out and
this is by many reasonable assessments a
war crime but by pretending that this is
now Russia that these four regions are
part of Russia and that the individuals
there are Russian because remember he's
quote annexed it
it's I don't I don't want to call it
plausible but it sort of is a one
percent attempt at claiming that what
you're doing is just the the governance
of your own country rather than an
alleged War crime so it's Bonkers and
it's crazy and of course we continue to
wonder about what is the end game here
there does not seem to be a face-saving
off-ramp for Vladimir Putin here and
increasingly the questions among the
United States and Western allies
continue to be
how far do we allow this to go and for
how long and what are the sort of red
lines at which point different
interventions would happen
for how long and to what degree and in
what particular ways do we again U.S
Western allies NATO Etc sort of these
vend Circles of those individual groups
continue to fund and Supply Ukraine and
um
at what point do we imagine that the
circumstances may change and there
aren't really good answers to that in
the U.S as is often the case the
conversation becomes what I call
toxically partisan and what I mean by
that is of course if different
individuals with different world views
would have different opinions about what
should be done in Russia obviously more
isolationist individuals would say we
should do nothing
we shouldn't even send money sent note
don't send arms send nothing at all
don't send legs don't send anything
um that's a joke by the way others would
say well we we send money but not arms
or we send money and arms but absolutely
nothing beyond that or well what about
training and then of course at the very
far end of that would be sort of boots
on the ground the unfortunate thing is
that when I say it's become toxically
partisan you have many right Wingers who
seek only to attack Joe Biden who take
the position that Biden is just wasting
money in Ukraine now a lot of these same
people earlier were saying Biden hasn't
done enough to protect the Ukrainian
people and Russia never would have even
invaded if Trump was President so you
you can't really get anywhere with about
60 to 70 percent of people on this issue
I I'm really willing to entertain
reasonable perspectives I don't want to
say from both sides but regardless of
political ideology I'm willing to
entertain reasonable perspectives that
will both uh not allow Russia to just
walk all over whoever they want to walk
over while also not committing or
involving the United States in a way
that would be
either counter counterproductive or not
particularly appropriate given that we
should not be the world's police any I'm
willing to entertain any reasonable
ideas that fall under that umbrella if
you have any as to what this should look
like feel free to email me last night
incumbent Republican Florida Senator
Marco Rubio was brutally crushed in a
disastrous debate for him by Challenger
democratic congresswoman Val demings I
have not seen a debate like this in a
long time and we've covered now close to
a dozen different 2022 debates Live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook as we tend
to do
I have not seen such a one-sided debate
until last night's debate where Val
demings just crushed Rubio he looked
despondent at certain points I also will
mention Rubio seemed not only like he
didn't want to be there but sort of like
he didn't think he needed to be there
his his attitude the entire debate was
that Val demmings is sort of beneath him
why does he have to waste his time as
the incumbent senator debating this
lowly other individual and she really
crushed him now before we look at some
clips I will mention demings wasn't
perfect she definitely wasn't perfect
there were a few moments where she gave
Rubio very good openings for easy and
effective rebuttals and you heard from
the crowd that they were effective there
were some moments that just weren't
perfect but she was really really good
demings came out a very very hot after
Rubio accused her of never having passed
any legislation let's just jump jump
right into these this is very
interesting he's been in Congress for
over half a decade she's never passed
the bill not PPP not anything not a
single Bill she's passed has ever become
law I'm proud of the fact we saved
millions of jobs I'm proud of the fact
we did it in a bipartisan way that's not
true I know the senator look and I'm
really disappointed in you a Marco Rubio
because adults I think there was a time
when you did not lie in order to win I
don't know what happened to you you know
that is not true my first term in this
in the United States house I passed
legislation to help Law Enforcement
Officers with mental health programs
your first term in the Senate you voted
to turn Medicare into basically to
abolish it and then turn it into an
underfunded voucher program and then you
gave the biggest tax break to The Riches
of the Rich and said you'd pay for it
because the Social Security and Medicare
now Not only was she very much prepared
for these attacks Val demings chose to
do something interesting during the
debate while Marco Rubio continued to
basically address the moderators
moderator Val demings regularly turned
to Marco Rubio and directly addressed
him now in our live chat there were some
people who said this is not a good
approach it's coming off as uh too
aggressive and confrontational Val
demings is trying to play from behind
here and we'll look at the polling in a
bit I actually think that this was
exactly right because when she would do
that when she would turn to Rubio Rubio
visibly shrank away he he shrank away
from the confrontation let's look at
more clips and these are these really
are good
um here's just enough these don't really
need necessarily introductions of course
the senator who has never run anything
at all but his mouth would know nothing
about helping people and being there for
people when they are in trouble no one
planned the pandemic but our response to
it is everything individuals were
hurting families were hurting businesses
were hurting we passed the cares act
which the senator supported there were
some problems in the cares act with the
paycheck protection program that you
love to take credit for some say it was
poorly written some say it didn't help
the people that it was supposed to
didn't save the jobs that it was
supposed to there was a way to fix the
problems in the PPP through the American
Rescue plan and help people that were in
trouble but you play a politics Senator
and you did not do that your number one
job is a United States Senator is to
protect the health safety and well-being
of the American people you've been at it
for 24 years
of course yeah she had a very good mix
of passion but also very specific claims
from Marco Rubio's legislative Pastor
lack thereof this came up again during
the topic of prescription drugs and it's
just hard to say anything other than
deming's was prepared and Rubio seemed
resentful of even having to be there he
talked about pharmaceuticals he voted
against legislation that would help
reduce the cost of prescription drugs
and help cap the cost of insulin
and Rubio again it it seemed that he was
unsure how to respond now one of the
other interesting things about Val
demings is they can't go after her with
one of the really popular slogans of
2022 which is your part of this defund
the police movement demings was a police
officer a police detective and a police
chief and her credentials as a supporter
of law enforcement while also supporting
reform make it very difficult to attack
her on those lines and when the topic of
gun violence came up
the difference
in not only knowledge but even
commitment to dealing with gun violence
was palpably different the majority of
people in our nation
want us to do just that how long will
you watch people being gunned down in
first grade fourth grade high school
college Church synagogue a grocery store
a movie theater a mall and a nightclub
Congressman do nothing yeah and that was
a critical moment of the debate in fact
where I think it sort of turned Rubio
seemed almost defeated after that point
his only real successes after that point
in the debate were when demings gave him
an opening by misstepping about his
legislative past and those are those are
certainly mistakes that she made
um on continuing on the issue of gun
violence it just was really not good for
Rubio's why are these people going out
there
this is the same argument and they don't
kill everyone I understand I want to go
to college one demings for 60 seconds
you know people who are
the families of
victims of gun violence just heard that
and they're asking themselves what in
the hell did he just say indeed
Senator you use the the Pulse Nightclub
shooting as your inspiration
to run again
for the senate in 2016. Parkland uh
pulse is in my district
and yet you've done nothing
nothing
to help address gun violence and get
dangerous weapons out of the hands of
dangerous people Florida after Parkland
after you made promises that you had no
intentions on keeping to the parents of
Parkland Florida passed legislation
raising the age
to have an assault weapon pass red flag
laws that we've seen 7 000 plus
instances where they've been used now
to our primary responsibility is the
safety of Floridians and Senator 24
years in elected office and you have not
yet risen to that occasion and they when
asked about it you say something that
makes no sense yeah and it didn't make
any sense Rubio was asked multiple times
you previously said you would support
changing the age requirement for buying
a rifle
and now you don't seem to why not and
Rubio just went in circles never
actually acknowledging yes I changed my
position and here's why I changed my
position and here's why
um one of the strangest moments was when
the topic of election Integrity you know
whatever they want to call they have all
these names that the name it's the name
you use already implies a particular
position but the topic of ballot drop
boxes came out and Rubio talked about
how dangerous they are
that's a method of voting that doesn't
Advantage one group or another there's
danger involved in drop boxes people
need to think about it okay imagine
someone decides oh there's a Dropbox I'm
just going to put some explosive in it
and blow it up and burn all those
ballots and now those votes don't count
at all why there is there's something
with elections there are two things that
are very important number one the count
has to be accurate the votes have to be
counted accurately but the other is
there has to be public confidence yeah
so Rubio's saying the reasons that
ballot drop boxes are bad are someone
might bomb the Dropbox okay I mean it
hasn't happened and I wouldn't
necessarily start giving people ideas
and he claims people don't have
confidence in the Dropbox as well the
first thing has never happened and he
probably shouldn't be encouraging people
to do it bombing a Dropbox the second
thing is the reason some people don't
have confidence in Dropbox is is because
people like Marco Rubio tell them that
they the dropboxes can't be trusted that
you shouldn't have confidence in them
it's a vicious circle
we need voting systems that people can
fight in and the reason people don't
confide in this one is because I told
them not to oh well stop telling them
not to confide in it and then we would
eliminate that problem
uh Rubio earlier in the debate said you
know on gun laws stricter gun laws don't
make a difference because the criminals
would find a way around it but then he's
saying well we got to get rid of the
drop boxes to avoid someone blowing one
up well wouldn't criminals just find a
different way to burn ballots if that's
what they were determined to do it
doesn't really make any sense one more
clip the topic of abortion came up and
there were a lot of Clips I could play
on this but in the interest of time
let's look at one in particular this is
really kind of emblematic of the dynamic
on this issue during yesterday's debate
so you talk about Lindsey Graham's bill
that's a four-month ban okay that is
more lenient than every country in
Europe except for two
the extremists on abortion in this
campaign is congresswoman demings she
supports no restrictions no limitations
of any kind by the way he said about six
or seven times that Val Deming supports
no limitations she multiple times said I
support no limitations up until the
gestational age of viability which I I
don't I think it's between 21 and 26
weeks roughly some somewhere in there
but he just kept repeating that lie he
voted against the form she's against the
four-month man she voted against a
five-month ban she she supports
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand for
any reason at any time up until the
moment of birth that's what she supports
that's the extreme position here I have
shown a willingness to work with people
to save unborn innocent human life she
opposes any limitation of any kind and
no one ever asks them about that
congresswoman Jennings
Senator how gullible do you really think
Florida voters are well the people
voting for Rubio are very gullible so
she's actually on to something there
number one you have been clear that you
support no exceptions
even including rape and incest now as a
police detective who investigated cases
of rape and incest no Senator I don't
think it's okay for a 10 year old girl
to be raped and have to carry the seed
of her rapist no I don't think it's okay
for you to make decisions for women and
girls as a senator I think those
decisions are made between the woman her
family her daughter and her faith and to
sit over or to stand over there and say
that I support don't support abortions
up to the time of birth it's just a lie
but to help protect the life of the
mother which you looked at that like it
was just well kind of a well that's kind
of a side issue
Senator you know that you have said you
don't support any exception so the
debate dramatically in deming's favor
the question is is it too little too
late because the polling is not
particularly good for Val deming's
latest uh Real Clear Politics average of
recent polling has Marco Rubio up 4.7
points just shy of Five Points that is a
big deficit to overcome in just two and
a half weeks or how long do we have left
until the election one two just under
three weeks it is a deficit to overcome
but let's hope that yesterday's debate
performance will help Val demings
overcome some of it one other thing it
always happens you know this this has
been going on for so long
when a woman like Val demings shows up
takes the aggressive approach
turns and looks at Rubio when she's
telling him that he's lying points to
Rubio
there are always reactions that oh she's
being too aggressive she's too assertive
etc etc and the same sort of demeanor
from male candidates is often seen as
powerful
commanding uh indicative of a control
over the issues and the circumstances
and there were indeed even people in my
chat yesterday saying oh deming's is
coming off too aggressive turning this
that the other thing I think she did I
genuinely think she did a great job she
did a fantastic job one of the best
debate performances so far not perfect
but very very close and let's see what
kind of ground if any Val demmings can
make up in the 20 or so days between now
and the election let me know your
thoughts your reaction to the debate you
can find me on Twitter at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show of course is a
viewer listener audience community
supported program I would love for you
to sign up at joinpakman.com do the
thing do the thing all the kids are
talking about it and the adults too I
have to say mostly adults we actually
don't have that many kids in our
audience you can sign up at
joinpakman.com get access to the Daily
bonus show the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show the members
only town halls and so much more and you
can use the coupon code Obama Obama to
get a a sizable discount more than 50
percent let me leave it there but you've
got to spell Obama correctly which it's
sort of like correctly incorrectly it's
o b a m n a That's Mike Nancy
o-b-a-m-n-a at joinpakman.com all right
let's talk a little bit about Carrie
Lake Carrie lake is the Republican
nominee for the Arizona gubernatorial
race Cary lake is one of the most
extreme candidates that has a shot at
winning
in this current slate of very deranged
and delusional uh Republicans that are
running and will be uh potentially
winning some of them in just about 20
days in a moment we will talk about an
unlikely
unless you've been paying attention an
unlikely supporter of Carrie Lake
showing up and campaigning for her her
name is Tulsi gabbard but we'll get to
that in a little bit over the weekend
and it's taken me time to get to this
because the shows have been so packed
Kerry Lake appeared on CNN and Carrie
Lake very clearly did not commit to
accepting the results of the election if
she were to lose now Kerry lake is
slicker than some of the other Mega nuts
where she was just able to say there's
no way I'm going to lose and I will of
course accept the results of me winning
but this is a way to avoid committing to
accepting the results if she loses and
we know she's not going to accept the
results if she loses how do we know well
even in the Republican primary which was
it took a while to get a final result
during the counting period including
when she fell behind she started crying
voter fraud so we know from what
happened a couple months ago that she's
not going to accept the results anyway
let's get to the clip here is Dana Bash
trying to pin her down on this my
question is will you accept the results
of your election in November
I'm gonna win the election and I will
accept that result if you lose will you
accept that
I'm gonna win the election and I will
accept that result because the people
will never the people of Arizona will
never support and vote for a coward like
Katie Hobbs who won't show up on a
debate stage she's saying you know I
said this regarding the White House
Press Secretary Kaylee mcineny's
comments in the summer of 2020. which
was you know the president
can't decide shouldn't be able to decide
whether to accept the results solely on
the basis of whether they have won or
they have lost but that's exactly what
Trump and Kaylee mcinanny were setting
Trump up to do in that summer of 2020.
it was I will accept it if I win but
it's going to be fraud if I lose and
Trump never said it in that language
Kaylee never said it in that language
but they made it clear there's all these
ways Democrats are going to try to steal
it and if indeed we lose by a little bit
it will be because Democrats have stolen
it but obviously if we win if we are
re-elected by the will of the people
which of course we will be then we will
accept that and at the time I said this
isn't how democracy is supposed to work
and it is happening again Republicans
will accept election results when they
win and if they don't win they will say
that it was fraudulent or it was stolen
or it was rigged or whatever the case
may be uh that is actual authoritarian
fascism that's not actually democracy
there was more of this very delusional
interview I'll play a little bit of it
for you here if leaders like you and
president Trump are saying that the
election was stolen aren't you
participating contributing even causing
the idea of people thinking that the
election is not safe and secure
no we are going to make sure our
elections are safe and secure for
Democrats Independents and Republicans
alike we want to know that our legal
vote counted we want to know the winner
on Election night we don't want to be
counting for 10 days but we want
everyone to know don't you want your
votes to be counted in games rail don't
you want your votes to be counted no
matter how long it takes in 2022 in
November Dana Dana I've been on the
campaign Trail for 500 and three days I
talked to moms and dads who are losing
children because of fentanyl poisoning I
talked to retirees who can't afford gas
and food I talk to parents whose
children are getting out of high school
and can't read we have serious problems
we totally agree I totally agree which
is why the election denial has Beyond
here Dana you want to have me on here
and talk 2020 election and you're like I
would never bring this up ever had you
not been bringing this up consistently
on the campaign Trail Carrie lake is
truly horrible
okay so now we get into the part that we
have already seen
this is a critical election in Arizona
I can't tell you how much of a joke the
United States will be seen as I mean
listen
Trump won in 2016. so the the being seen
as a joke would not be new
but this woman is a cartoon and sadly
she's winning right now the real clear
politics average for the Arizona
gubernatorial race between Carrie Lake
and Katie Hobbs has Carrie Lake 1.6
points ahead
1.6 points ahead with a new DW Trafalgar
poll having her plus three
uh that being said there's a KPHO poll
from four days prior which has Katie
Hobbs up one but the message here is and
we've got a great Tick Tock video
actually about this
Kerry Lake could win
and turn Arizona
into truly a laughing stock of the
United States globally where people are
emailing me saying what the hell is
wrong with these people particularly
Kerry Lake they may do it they may do it
and so I hope that all of our Arizona
voters are planning to vote uh
this is one we'll be watching very
closely all right so one more sort of
Carrie Lake story but it's also a Tulsi
gabbard story I don't know that I have
to rehash the entire story but Tulsi
gabbard is a former democratic
congresswoman she ran for president back
in 2020 for the Democratic primary and
at the time I told you guys this is not
really a leftist this is a grifter this
is not an interesting candidate she's
not bringing interesting ideas she's
just bamboozling people and many in my
audience understood that some did not
and they said Tulsi is the last real
liberal she's truly the anti-war
candidate she's truly this that the
other thing okay
obviously untrue cut to last week Tulsi
says I'm no longer a Democrat and in Her
speech leaving the Democratic party she
lists a whole bunch of different
conspiracy theories anti-white racism
wokism
um an elitist cabal that's in control it
is like it's almost like Q Anon stuff
but she's an independent now she's a
Centrist and she's take blah blah okay
who's she campaigning for last night
Kerry Lake
Carrie like Tulsi gabbard widely
promoted as showing up in support of
Kerry Lake one of the most extreme
candidates running in 2022 who has a
chance to win I will tell you a little
bit about that in a moment but here are
Tulsi and Carrie throwing bouquets at
each other
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know what's amazing the young
Republicans are not just the future they
are the Republican Party the new
Republic
[Applause]
[Music]
um Austin yeah
um Tulsi gabbard who wants us to believe
that she is no longer part of the
democratic party but she's still a
Centrist she still holds many
Progressive or at least left-leaning
values and she sees the good of both
sides and all this stuff one of her
first acts as an independent having left
defiantly and because of her principles
and values left the Democratic party one
of her first acts is to show up in
support of Carrie Lake who led anti-mask
rallies anti-mask masks guys told a
group of Republican retirees she was
preemptively prophylactically taking
hydroxychloroquine to avoid getting
coveted 19. that's something Kerry Lake
said to people
um Carrie Lake said that if she becomes
Governor she will work to have
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin
produced in Arizona to make it easier to
get people those like life-saving Cova
drugs which of course don't do anything
to help when you have coveted as
demonstrated by actual medical trials
she accused Joe Biden and Democrats of
having a quote demonic agenda she's
doing the demonic stuff and Tulsa goes
now that I'm a clear thinking
independent I'm going to go and support
Carrie Lake uh Carey Lake expressed
support for Banning both Surgical and
medication abortions outright in Arizona
and of course Kerry Lake for nearly two
years has been a leading voice
arguing
that Trump won the 2020 election when he
very clearly and obviously lost
Kerry lake is a disgusting ideologue an
extremist reactionary
and now that Tulsi gabbard is seeing the
world more clearly because she's no
longer part of the Democratic Party
she chooses to go and say Here's who I'm
supporting Carrie Lake
absolutely disgusting and I've been
hearing from dozens of our viewers over
the last week since Tulsi bailed on the
Democratic Party
dozens of our viewers saying David I
fell for it I fell for it and I feel so
stupid now
it was so obvious guys Tulsi gabbard was
not what she claimed to be and now she's
campaigning for Kerry Lake we'll have
these clips by the way that I played on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so the
Kanye West anti-Semitism anti-jewish
comments just will not stop we have
another short interview to look at and
again the I want to really explain to
you all the reason I'm content I don't
care about Kanye West I don't care about
him as an artist and I don't care about
him as part of the cultural milieu what
concerns me about Kanye West is that it
is the prototypical example of a guy who
is saying insane things about Jews and
it's just not taken as seriously in
social media and elsewhere
as it would be if it was some other
individual a white person for example
attacking a different group and this is
the soft indifference to anti-Semitism
that I have spoken about before West is
unhinged let's look at some clips he was
interviewed by Chris Cuomo now on news
nation which is the it's a new channel
of some kind
asked about the anti-semitic comments
themselves and here's what he had to say
couldn't it also be that you have said
things that offend the community
guidelines like anti-semitic comments
and things that are seen as insensitive
uh and potentially threatening to
communities that we try to protect
[Music]
well I don't like the term anti-Semitic
a lot of anti-semites don't it's been a
term that's allowed
people specifically in my industry to
get away
to get away with murder sometimes
literally wow literal murder is
happening because of the word
anti-Semitism you know and get away
doing bad people people a lot of robbing
happens because of the word
anti-Semitism this is this is sick I
always say I got screwed on a deal is it
would that become a surprise to you if I
said hey a music exec screwed someone on
a deal does that sound kind of like
normal commonplace to you so for me it
doesn't have anything to do with being
anti-Semitic
it does if you're Kanye because his
argument is that the Jews are screwing
him yes you believe that all record
producers are Jewish or you know it's
when you talk about Jewish people
specifically he is targeting them that
creates a problem anti-semitic but I
don't believe in that term one thing is
he doesn't believe in it guys imagine if
someone said after after throwing around
the n-word and they were like that's
that's insanely racist and they go I
don't believe in the term racist oh all
right well I guess it's fine black
people all situ I classify as Jew also
so I actually can't be an anti-semite so
so the term yeah Kanye can't be
anti-semitic because he also is Jew as
he likes to say I'm not gonna do the
full explanation now about uh this
entire black Israelite 12 lost tribes
thing I've already done it a bunch of
times before but that movement in and of
itself is quite a racist movement
um here's another segment from this just
completely delusional interview in which
Kanye says he's been texting with Kid
Rock which doesn't income is a huge
surprise to me I must say it's actually
something Kid Rock uh just gave me a
text about that go to places where
you're celebrated not where you're just
tolerated oh you know I bring a lot he's
his Kanye's upset that his aunties he
has very in a very he wants to be given
some kind of prize for calling out the
Jews essentially he's not being
celebrated for his anti-Semitism of
uh
I bring a lot of
attention to these platforms to
Instagram and to Twitter and they Silo
you they they Shadow ban you everyone
knows that was Shadow bad on Instagram
yeah and what's Wild is he's even using
the Reddit rhetoric of these right
Wingers the right Wingers always tell me
David you've Shadow banned me on your
platform and they get it from prominent
right-wingers and Republicans who have
been talking about Shadow bands for a
while uh and now Kanye is using it this
guy's disgusting it's not getting the
reaction that I believe it deserves and
now potentially Kanye is going to buy
himself social media platform parlor
which we talked about on yesterday's
bonus show a failed former president
Donald Trump was given the opportunity
to respond to uh Kanye West's
anti-semitic comments now this was an
interesting um question this was with uh
Larry O'Connor Joe O'Connor Larry
O'Connor from the Salem News uh Channel
and Kanye has praised Trump before and
when you praise Trump trump will rarely
criticize you no matter what you do no
matter what you say even though Donald
Trump has uh a Jewish Daughter by
conversion and a Jewish son-in-law and
Jewish grandkids and all this stuff
Trump we know Harbors many anti-semitic
beliefs but he's also not going to
attack Kanye over this would be my guess
because Kanye is nice to Trump and likes
Trump and indeed Trump downplayed uh
Kanye's anti-semitic comments in this
just complete implosion of an interview
he's been saying some really uh
offensive things lately about your own
son-in-law Jared Kushner and about
Jewish people uh Jewish Americans yeah
he's attacking your family writ large uh
could you react to that because is this
the guy that you knew
well I haven't really seen the
statements he's made give me a break
dude did watch the Tucker Carlson
interview and he was really nice to me
that's what that's all that matters
that's all that matters listen the
anti-semitic comments including the ones
against my own son-in-law that I didn't
see but he had great reviews for me when
he spoke to Tucker and by the way Tucker
cut out anti-semitic elements of that
interview as well which we later
obtained Beyond anybody he was he was
great to me and he was great really to
Mega to The Mega Movie it was very
impressive I I was uh you know not
surprised I got I always got along with
them I liked him I've always gotten
along with them uh so I don't really
know what statements humid sometimes
he'll make a statement and a lot of
people will uh think it's worse than he
means it to be right guys Kanye's
overtly anti-semitic statements
including listing a dozen different
anti-semitic tropes in that drink
whatever interview that I played for you
earlier this week
it was all blown up and taken out of
context I think that uh you know I was I
was uh it's certainly very uh you you
know what I'm talking about he was
really high on a guy named Donald Trump
yeah he's been saying some um Trump's
approaches
I don't care what he says as long as
he's nice to me that that's
fundamentally what it is
um let's look at a little bit more of
this interview the entire interview is
bizarre again let's get all those
questions answered I'm very proud to be
joined by the 45th president Donald
Trump Mr President thank you for joining
us tonight well thank you very much
Larry it's an honor I know that you're
focusing on the 2022 primaries you're
doing your your rallies and I know that
there's a lot of candidates that you
single-handedly endorse the latest
polling shows a red wave coming how much
credit do you think you deserve for
what's about to happen that's a that's a
really good question to open it up with
how much should we be praising you for
any Republican win in November sir
well I think we deserve a lot of credit
for having done a really good job over
four years so that we had no inflation
we had the greatest economy in the
history of our country we had the
strongest border ever we defeated Isis
uh we would have never had the
catastrophe that's going on in Ukraine
that was not something that would ever
have happened a hundred percent we're
energy independent we were going to be
energy dominant in a period of very
short period of time right you know we
would have been supplying the world with
energy we would have made a fortune we
would have brought down the taxes and
many other things right we rebuilt the
military a lot of a lot of things that
we did was that 12 lies in 90 seconds is
that is that actually what I just heard
so as you can imagine not exactly
a significant journalistic rigor during
this very strange interview but listen
if you're nice to Trump you can get away
with saying anything even overtly
anti-semitic comments about Trump's own
son-in-law must be nice to just have
that simple moral guidepost if they say
nice things about me I'll say nice
things about them we'll take a quick
break and be back after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's look at a couple other
things that I have for you today I'm
going to play a clip for you now from
what is supposedly the straight news I
don't mean heterosexual by the way I
think when I'm talking about Fox News
it's important to clarify Fox News does
this thing where they say okay listen
we have our straight news and we have
our opinion
sure the opinion side has a right-wing
lean because those are the individuals
we have they are allowed to give their
views and say whatever they want but
when we do news when we do Straight news
our anchors they are just doing news now
we all know that that's not true we know
we've been known for years that that's
not true one of the techniques that the
fox straight news shows will do
to do the very same opinion that the
opinion shows do is Tucker Carlson or
Sean Hannity at night will give some
disgusting opinion about something and
then the next day Fox News hard news
shows report on the opinion
as if it is newsworthy right so Tucker
will go oh immigrants make our country
dirty and poor
but that's opinion the next day the
anchor who doesn't do opinion goes a Fox
News uh host Tucker Carlson says that
immigrants make our country dirtier and
poorer is this true or not now we debate
that with one talking head versus
another talk okay so you know that
technique but Harris Faulkner is a
particular Fox News straight news anchor
who is increasingly straight up using
Tucker Carlson and other Fox News hosts
disgusting rhetoric about immigrants to
the point that she's openly using Nazi
type rhetoric now on her uh program I
guess we call it Okay let's listen to
what she had to say yesterday cop Y and
ear Senator thank you for being in Focus
today yeah
thank you Harris The Fallout over the
bombshell report on the DHS asking for
military volunteers to do chores
for people who've shown up at our border
including picking up the garbage after
them now I've shown you on this very
program an exclusive video that they
leave a trail of unspeakables from The
River's Edge until they can enter
someplace illegally
where there are no border patrol nobody
there to stop them some sensors that
that are very very slow to respond to
because there's so many of them
they make our country look like what
they left and now our people are going
to be picking up all that trash and all
that excrement
it's in Focus oh boy what a hard-hitting
story
um this is essentially straight up
Nazi style rhetoric that Nazis used
about Jews which now many of these right
Wingers are using about hispanic
immigrants from a central in South
America it's it they have been building
up to this on Fox news for a long time
okay this is essentially using Tucker
Carlson's poorer and dirtier rhetoric
about immigrants they make our country
look like the
crappy place they left behind the trash
that they left behind and now we're
going to be going around picking up
their trash and excrement this is
straight up textbook what the type of
stuff that used to be said about Jews oh
they bring disease and they bring filth
and they infect and they get released
into the wild sort of like animalistic
type dehumanizing language and
understand that what I showed you is
supposedly ostensibly not opinion
journalism that's that's the news hour
on Fox News
um it's just overt at this point in time
and so when we wonder you know how can
these what we call primary Fox News
viewers people who primarily get their
news from Fox News how do they believe
so much stuff that's not true how do
they believe lies about climate change
the election
vaccines taxes the economy oil electric
vehicles how how is it that they believe
just so much stuff that's not true it's
because they only watch Fox News or
almost only watch Fox News they can't
tell the difference between news and
opinion and what is a fact and what is
an opinion
and Fox News deliberately makes it
difficult and by difficult I mean you
know like
an intelligent person would be able to
tell the difference but Fox doesn't help
distinguish between its opinion and news
shows and this is the type of stuff you
get absolutely disgusting one other
thing from Fox News that is just
laughable
Fox Nation which is the streaming
Network for Fox News they're doing a
mock trial of Hunter Biden yeah I no no
I didn't say Joe Biden they're doing a
mock trial of Hunter Biden you know they
talk about impeaching Joe Biden to which
we often say for what for what for what
but if they did a mock trial of Joe
Biden at least Joe Biden's the president
but that's not what they're doing they
are doing a mock trial for Hunter Biden
it's fiction programming okay take a
look at this promo Hunter Biden is the
most protected person in the country
what money laundering illegal foreign
you have the laptop Infamous big guy
email
the son of the vice president is doing
deals funded by the Chinese government
there are so many inclusive evidence
to me has ignored it because they wanted
Joe Biden elected president
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I am
here to defend Hunter Biden
so we're attempting to influence policy
objection your honor
let's look at photographs this is what I
think of these photographs we really
have no way of knowing what was said
between him and these people
80 commit bribery your honor if you're
going to try my case try not to lose it
at this time the prosecution rests the
trial of Hunter Biden streaming all this
week
oh my goodness how can we even take this
seriously you know this could be so
devastating I don't know that anyone's
gonna vote for Hunter Biden after this
program oh he's not running for anything
oh fictional programming for their
endlessly gullible audience and again
we see these interviews at a trump rally
and these people are obsessed with
Hunter Biden and we're like why where is
this stuff coming from it's coming from
places like this it's coming from this
type of programming uh Mr Biden you're
being charged with two counts of a
laptop from hell and two counts of the
Biden crime family how do you plea I
really wish they would stop trying to
make this Hunter Biden stuff happen but
it's also a reminder of how vapid and
vacant there they are in terms of having
anything else they don't have anything
else to work with this is all they have
at this point in time and yes I know
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
say that they're going to impeach Joe
Biden okay they seem they all seem much
much more focused on Hunter Biden it's
pathetic it's humiliating and again
remember one of the ways in which Fox
News has become what it is and Fox
Nation is the stream dreaming arm of Fox
News one of the ways they've done it
is they blur the lines between reality
and fiction and they blur the lines
between news and opinion and
I do we call this a film I don't know
what I don't know if it's a series or a
film
this mock trial of Hunter Biden is the
epitome of appealing to low information
folks who lack all media literacy
blurring opinion and news fact and
fiction and hopefully nobody watches it
it looks like it's going to be a
complete and total disaster we have a
voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here is a voicemail about
the new Finance Channel yes we have a
finance Channel youtube.com
pacmanfinance you know we get so many
voicemails from people who just don't
understand what the hell I'm talking
about and I usually blame myself I must
be a terrible Communicator this caller
knows exactly what the Pacman Finance
channel is and is supposed to be take a
listen
hey David I'd like to thank you so much
for you know uh creating the passman
finance uh YouTube channel thank you I
really like the content that you've been
producing it's very simple
um nothing too Exquisite like talking
about oh which stock should I buy or
when should I buy Tesla just really
simple you know personal finance that I
really feel like a lot of people are
missing out today especially in regards
to uh credits to uh credit scores
learning how to budget uh stuff like
that and I mean
and also the fact that you know you're
not like Dave Ramsey that's also a very
refreshing thing so yes yeah again thank
you so much for creating the Pacman
Finance Channel and I look forward to
seeing you know seeing the channel you
know get up to you know one million well
listen I don't know about a million
subscribers but I have to tell you
the Pacman Finance channel has grown
more quickly out of the gate to 10 000
subscribers than any other channel or
project we've been involved in now I
want to remind everybody I have nothing
to sell you it is an alternative to
these right-wing Finance folks Dave
Ramsey who gives Financial advice but
he's anti-vaxx and has horrible
Employment Practices he's been accused
of at his organization you don't need
that you can get all the information
without the anti-vaxx nuttery okay so
indeed there's no stock picking there's
none of that check out the channel
youtube.com
pacmanfinance more than 11 000
subscribers it's all free there's
nothing you even could pay for if you
wanted it's all free
so many basic personal finance topics I
always say we should start teaching this
stuff to 12 year olds
and we don't so we're offering it for
free on the channel okay
recent topics the hidden cost of low
prices okay how low prices can actually
lead to more spending is it better to
pay with cash or credit cards
understanding the math of retirement
why health insurance is important Roth
versus traditional IRAs understanding
net worth why the stock market has been
down improving your credit score why you
shouldn't bother trying to time the
market all of these things it is just
free simple topics okay youtube.com
pacmanfinance if more folks knew the
stuff and understood the content that
was on this channel we would have way
fewer people fall for financial scams
number one and in general people would
be better off in terms of understanding
their financial position no stock picks
If You're Expecting stock picks this is
not the channel for you if you're
expecting anti-vax this is not the
channel for you go to Dave Ramsey for
the anti-vax finance stuff youtube.com
Pacman Finance okay enough
on today's bonus show great bonus show
today
yet another acquittal
related to Durham Trump and Republicans
have been saying oh Durham's going to
get this person that person it's going
to be crazy yet another Durham acquittal
it's a humiliation for the right Wingers
the White House is pushing ahead on a
plan to research the idea of cooling the
Earth by reflecting sunlight back out
into space
discussed in science fiction for decades
could it become a reality we will talk
about it today on the bonus show and
also I know that I just told you that
the new British prime minister uh
replacing Boris Johnson is Liz trust
she's been in what a few weeks she's
already only Hanging On by a thread
party members are calling for her to be
removed and this could be one of the
shortest tenures as British prime
minister in British history fascinating
I guess not good for Liz truss but maybe
good for the people of the UK all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well many of our viewers do
thank their lucky stars every single day
that they have access to the bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you on the bonus show or otherwise back
here tomorrow
foreign